[Musik]
nach freunde ich will hier geradezu mit
meiner familie war ein bisschen auf tik
tok unterwegs und habe mir war wieder
sehr lustige sehr coole tecdax
angeschaut und habe ich mir gedacht ich
zeig dir euch einfach mal ja auch so was
muss erstmal kommen und soviele
langeweile muss man vor allem erstmal
haben wie es ist wenn man nachts die
lichter ausmacht besonders der furz am
ende war stark machen allerdings sei
weiter mit dem nächsten schock video wo
eine junge einfach die sirene der
polizei eins zu eins nach machen kann
[Musik]
ja und jetzt zeigt jetzt eine nette
person wie man einen milchshake macht in
aller welt
machen wir direkt weiter mit einer
person die im flugzeug aus dem fenster
guckt und das hier entdeckt
entspannt extrem entspannt am nächsten
tag doch video geht es darum dass zwei
personen ihre ski verloren haben und
dann mit einem tisch den berg runter
gefahren sind
[Musik]
und beim nächsten tipp doch videos meist
ein mädchen ihre nudeln weg allerdings
klappt das nicht so ganz mit dem
mülheimer die nächste person ist im
mediamarkt und testet ein paar zahlen
würden
und
die nächste person fällt schlichtweg
einfach auf die fresse bekommen aber ich
bin gekommen
was sagst du dazu ich bin der kastl auch
aller zeiten amk
ja ich auch ich fünfmal die 2000 jahre
später
[Musik]
wir schauen uns jetzt auf jeden fall das
nächste video an bei dem ein mädchen
richtig krass gestaffelt ist dabei ist
er allerdings dann ihr handy raus zu
gefallen und sie hat ihr handy außerdem
weggetreten
[Musik]
ja blöd gelaufen der nächste tipp user
trifft allerdings spongebob also den
sprecher von spongebob auf der straße
ich finds halt immer so heftig so die
leute hinter den gesprochenen figuren
irgendwie in echter mal zu sehen so wie
die aussehen und so weiter und so fort
allerdings machen wir direkt mit dem
nächsten tor video und zwar es ist eine
versinnbildlichung falls das wort
existiert von der batterie eines handys
[Musik]
also meinem freundeskreis ist es so dass
viele gerade erst richtig anfangen tik
tok zu nutzen weil die app halt so
gerade am komplett explodieren ist ich
habe heute übrigens auch im neuesten
video hochgeladen also könnt ihr auch
gern mal vorbeischaut laser luca
allerdings könnt ihr ja gern bei uns in
die kommentare schreiben
die bei euch so aussieht also welche app
bei euch den meisten akku
ich kann mich gar nicht ernst nehmen
wenn hier misst dann auch neben mir ist
also ich will eigentlich packen jetzt
erst mal weg ein gutes beispiel dafür
dass man bei sie sturm nicht draußen auf
einem schiff stehen sollte
das find ich ja beispielsweise auch mega
ist es ist nicht mehr so wie beim
musical das man halt irgendwie was mit
musik machen konnte sondern konnte auch
einfach - hochladen
so wie beispielsweise auch das hier
[Musik]
ja
ist ein bisschen was kaputt gegangen
manchmal allerdings weiter mit dem
nächsten tor video und zwar seine nach
einfach gar nichts geht schon was das
talent von der person
o
ja genau so habe ich auch reagiert als
ich das gesehen habe und das nächste
video wird auch recht amüsant
[Musik]
[Applaus]
allerdings direkt weiter mit dem
nächsten kick dem video das am morgen
maschine ja keine ahnung nächstes dem
video ist die wahrheit ist wirklich 100
prozent die wahrheit beim nächsten check
your video geht's ich brauch eigentlich
gar nicht sagen worum es geht weil das
sieht jetzt selber alter oder typen auf
dem computer der bühne zeigen
ja
ich hoffe mal geburtstag nicht
festgenommen achmer allerdings weiter
mit dem nächsten tor video und zwar war
dass ich am wochenende
jedes mal wenn ich mir das angucken muss
ich einfach nicht verlassen und man sich
wahrscheinlich auch wehgetan hat auch
was ein übergang alter also es ist auf
jeden fall die nächste person
[Musik]
irgendwie fühle ich mich schlecht dafür
dass ich lache wenn man auf jeden fall
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten techno
video ist es diesmal kein krasser fällt
oder irgendwas lustige sondern ist etwas
atemberaubendes und zwar pint eine
person einen notizzettel an seinen
reding mit dem man dem bleistift
anspitzen kann
schaut euch einfach an
[Musik]
ich weiß
sito normalzeit ist feige aus das
nächste tik tok ist allerdings wieder
etwas lustiges weil es war immerhin
stehen nein das nächste tik tok
ein bisschen ekelhaft aber schaut
einfach selbst
ja
machen wir weiter mit dem nächsten
meisterwerk heute könnt ihr dieses
geräusch edelmann kohle
ich habe das auch ziemlich stumpf dumm
ist und wahrscheinlich auch ziemlich weh
getan hat ist das nächste video
ich hoffe dein arsch geht es gut wir
machen allerdings sei weiter mit dem
nächsten kick top videos was ist eine
person die krank war und dabei sich eine
mundharmonika dem mund gesteckt hat
fragt mich nicht warum aber schaut
einfach besser als ich im
musikunterricht alle die hier gerade zu
schauen und regelmäßig tik tok nutzen
wissen dass das so ist bei mir ist es so
häufig so ich bin immer vom einschlafen
locker eine stunde noch auf sieg doch
schauen wir sachen an und dann will ich
kann und ich habe die ganze zeit diese
komischen wieder im kopf machen
allerdings sei weiter mit dem nächsten
video wo eine person alle apple geräte
in einem apple store die gleiche wecker
ding das war kein richtiges deutsch aber
seht einfach selbst
[Musik]
nein
wieviel klatsche ich eigentlich im
heutigen video schreibt mal die anzahl
an unten in die kommentare
normalerweise eher weniger jetzt meine
damen und herren kommen wir allerdings
auch schon zum letzten takt auf video
das sich für das heutige video hier raus
gesucht habe und zwar ist es ein video
was wirklich rote manners also manieren
auf der straße darstellt und zwar in
ziemlich überspitzter form aber ich
glaube jeder schon mal selbst auto
gefahren ist sieht sich in der situation
wieder an der stelle würden missbrauch
und ich das heute wieder seine band
meine lieben freunde wenn ich ein paar
tagen eventuell nochmal euch irgendwie
krasse lustige oder die besten tecdax
meiner meinung nach vorstellen sondern
schreibe gerne in die kommentare das ein
like unter dem video da und ich würde an
der stelle nun auch sagen hallo hast du
gut geschlafen hast du gut gegessen auch
okay bis dahin